herbert du warst damals selbst dabei als
die furchtbare katastrophe
passierte wie erinnerst du dich daran
die ja das war natürlich ein tag der wie
wir alle wissen ganz normal begonnen hat
strahlender sonnenschein hatte ein
appartement wo ich die in den nordturm
sehen konnte die sonne hat sich darin
gespiegelt ganz normaler tag kaffee
getrunken e mails gecheckt und daneben
ging es los mit diesem erstaunlichen
flugzeug geräusch das man gehört das war
völlig laut total laut kam näher dann
hörte das heulen der triebwerke und dann
starte ich ins world trade center und
sah wie die explosions planen daraus
geschossen sind das ganze natürlich ein
riesenschock zuerst habe ich persönlich
noch an einen unfall glaubt das ganze
natürlich wurde zunichte gemacht diese
hoffnung 20 minuten später habe wieder
dieses flugzeug geräusch gehört ist es
hören der triebwerke dieser einschlag
dieses echo dass man dann gehört in
lower manhattan und es war eben die
zweite maschine der südturm amerika war
angegriffen von al-kaida-terroristen das
war klar da hat man natürlich
friedman dann eigentlich fast 1 hat ein
bisschen auch angst natürlich bin dann
hinunter habe berichtet mit überlebenden
geredet und war dann am broadway
ungefähr zwei blöcke drei blöcke weg der
südturm also eingestürzt ist und hier
natürlich diese schreckliche szenen als
die staubwolke durch lower manhattan
gerast ist der ich selbst bin dann unter
einen lieferwagen gehechtet am boden
gelegen die staubwolke drüber es war
komplett finster totenstill wenn der
film gerissen wäre
dann atmet man das world trade center
ein und ich liege da am bauch unter
diesem wagen und habt ihr einen moment
die glaubte ich ersticke hier hatte
gerade vor ein paar wochen gelernt dass
meine frau schwanger ist dass ich vater
werde das sind schon momente wo man dann
wirklich
sehr emotional wird auch ein wenig
todesangst hat bin dann aus von dem auto
von diesem lieferwagen hervorgekrochen
und das haben wir dann schon ein
bisschen das licht durchkommen und bin
dann sofort zurück apartment meine frau
natürlich nichts wusste was mit mir
passiert ist das schon für mich
persönlich ganz dramatische szenen um
für die anderen natürlich in new york
auch diese schrecken szenen die man nie
vergessen wird als menschen aus dem
world trade center gesprungen sind ich
habe das selbst einige einige gesehen
das sind alles momente die selbst 20
jahre nach nach diesem furchtbaren
terroranschlags rechts sehen als wäre
das ganze gestern passiert
du bist gerade wieder in new york
natürlich momentan ist es noch sehr früh
bei euch wo stehst du genau und was wird
am morgen passieren
hinter mir kann man die skyline von new
york erkennen das ist eine neue skyline
natürlich die zwillingstürme sind wecker
wurden ersetzt durch in one world trade
center turm der ungefähr genauso hoch
ist
wieder der wiederaufbau von ground zero
die tatort ist mittlerweile
abgeschlossen new york hat auch
insgesamt natürlich viele hochhäuser
dazugekommen ist eine größere modernere
stadt geworden aber natürlich an solchen
tagen an diesen jahres tagen erhält die
stadt eine erinnert sich an die sich an
dieses schreckliche
schrecklichen vorfälle natürlich man
darf auch nicht vergessen
an den in den tagen danach wurde das
ganze menschliche leid dieser tragödie
erkennbar auf kommt dieser vermissten
fotos die überall gegangen sind es sind
ja mehr als 2700 menschen hier in new
york gestorben das ist eine große anzahl
von todesopfern auch wieso eine große
stadt und an diese momente erinnert sich
new york jedes jahr und jetzt natürlich
ganz besonders zum zwanzigsten jahrestag
[Musik]